this
is what happens when lava mixes with
water
but luckily this only happens
in a small portion of our world
but what if that wasn't the case
and lava filled up our oceans
what might happen then
how long would something like this take
why would this change the weather
and how hot would earth get
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we filled our oceans up with lava
if you think something like this is
impossible because
we don't have enough lava in the world
think again
there's enough magma in the earth's
mantle to fill our oceans
650 times
but this process wouldn't be overnight
so how long would it take
well this would be a slow process
if we erupted all volcanoes at once
to fill our oceans entirely with lava
that process would take over 32
000 years but that doesn't mean the fun
wouldn't begin right away as soon as
lava
started to reach the ocean it would
react with the water
creating a lava haze these plumes of
smoke
come when lava connects with water and
they're comprised
of hydrochloric acid gas steam
as well as tiny volcanic particles
so in short this is something you don't
want
anywhere near you if you do come in
contact with this smoke
it can cause lung eye and skin
irritation
and usually when smoke like this does
happen
it's in a small contained area so humans
could evacuate to some place safer
but in our scenario these lava plumes
would be everywhere it would be
practically
impossible to escape not only that but
the wind would also carry the smoke
further spreading it around the world
but that's just what humans would
experience
what about all the ocean wildlife
well unfortunately for them anything
inside the oceans would be boiled alive
this would also be a problem for humans
as
three and a half billion depend on the
ocean as their primary source of food
as the wildlife died the water in the
ocean
would boil and evaporate even more
greenhouse gases and fumes would be
released into the atmosphere
as the oceans continued to fill all the
increased smoke and
fog would reduce the amount of sunlight
that reaches the planet
this would cause plants and crops to
completely die out
and now that the ocean is full of lava
the
earth would be incredibly hot
for reference lava can be as hot as 1200
degrees
and the heat it radiates is scorching as
well
people flying above pools of lava from
hundreds of feet in the air
have reported feeling immense heat
so if lava covered 70 percent of the
earth's surface
the temperature would be thousands of
degrees and
would instantly cook you to a crisp
if you somehow managed to survive this
well
good luck with the earth's new weather
system
that's because the heat from the lava
would mix with
cooler air inland and this would create
a
fire cloud that would produce violent
lightning storms and
generate extreme winds to get a better
sense of what might happen
we can look to the past billions of
years ago
earth looked quite a bit like this
it was full of lava and had no way of
supporting life
but as hundreds of millions of years
passed
the lava cooled and solidified
earth could now sustain life and
that's what would happen in our scenario
hundreds of millions of years would pass
and the lava would eventually cool down
enough for the planet to be
inhabitable again and hopefully
humanity would have devised a plan to
get off the planet
as it was filling with lava but
that sounds like a story for another
what if